it's a super exciting time and it's
certainly something that we are
investing very heavily in right now at
Microsoft in the particular sense of
like how do we take the best of our
development tools the best of our
platform technology the best of our a I
and the best of our cloud to let people
build these solutions where it's not as
hard as it is right now you're listening
to the Microsoft Research podcast a show
that brings you closer to the cutting
edge of technology research and the
scientists behind it I'm your host
Gretchen using
[Music]
Kevin Scott has embraced many roles over
the course of his illustrious career in
technology software developer
engineering executive researcher angel
investor philanthropist and now chief
technology officer of Microsoft but
perhaps no role suits him so well or has
so fundamentally shaped all the others
as his self-described role of all-around
geek today in a wide-ranging interview
Kevin shares his insights on both the
history in the future of computing talks
about how his impulse to celebrate the
extraordinary people behind the tech led
to an eponymous nonprofit organization
and a podcast and reveals the super
power he got when he was in grad school
that and much more on this episode of
the Microsoft Research podcast Kevin
Scott welcome to the podcast today well
thank you so much for having me so you
said in a big chair I think our
listeners would like to know what it's
like to be the chief technical officer
of Microsoft how do you envision your
role here and what do you hope to
accomplish in your time ie what are the
big questions you're asking the big
problems you're working on what gets you
up in the morning well there are tons of
big problems I guess the biggest and the
one that excites me most and that
prompted me to take the job in the first
place is I think technology is playing
an increasingly important role and how
the future of the world unfolds and you
know has an enormous impact in our
day-to-day lives from the mundane to the
profound and I think having a
responsible philosophy about how you
build technology it's like a very very
important thing for the technology
industry to do so in addition to solving
all of these sort of complicated
problems of the how what technology do
we build and how do we build it there's
also an if and a why that we need to be
addressing as well drill in a little
there the if and the why those are two
questions
love talk to me about how you envision
that you know I think one of the more
furious debates that we all are
increasingly having and I think the
debate itself and the intensity of the
debate are good things as sort of around
AI and what impact is AI going to have
on our future and what's the right way
to build it and what are a set of wrong
way is to build it and I think this is
sort of a very important dialogue for us
to be having because in general I think
AI will have a huge impact on our
collective futures I actually most super
optimistic person by Nature and I think
the impact that it's gonna have is gonna
be absolutely astoundingly positive and
beneficial for Humanity but there's also
this other side of the debate where to
go there later I'm going to ask you
about that so we'll talk a little bit
about the dark side but also you know I
love the framework I hear that over and
over from researchers here at Microsoft
Research that are optimistic and saying
and if there are issues we want to get
on the front end of them and start to
driving and influence how those things
get play out so yeah absolutely there's
a way to think about AI where it's
mostly about building a set of
automation technologies that are direct
substitute for human labor and you can
use those tools and technologies to
cause disruption but a I'm probably is
going to be more like the steam engine
in the sense that the steam engine was
also a direct substitute for human labor
and the people that benefited from it
initially were those who had the capital
to build them because they were
incredibly expensive and who had the
expertise to design them and to operate
and maintain them and eventually the
access of this technology fully
democratized and AI will eventually
become that our role as a technology
company that is building things that
empower individuals and businesses
democratize access to the technology as
quickly as possible and to do that in a
safe thoughtful ethical way let's talk
about you for a second you've described
yourself as an engineering executive an
angel investor and an all-around geek
tell us how you came by each of those
metatags yeah the geek was the one that
was sort of unavoidable it felt to me
all my life like I was a geek I I was
this precociously curious child not in
the sense of you know like playing this
piano concertos well five years old
anything now that I was the irritating
flavor of precocious where I'm sticking
metal objects and electric sockets and
taking apart everything that could be
taken apart my mom's house try to figure
out how things worked and I've had just
sort of weird geeky obsessive tastes and
things my entire life and I think a lot
of everything else just sort of flows
from me at some point fully embracing
that geekiness and wanting I mean so
like angel investing for instance is me
wanting to give back it's like I
benefited so much over the course of my
career from folks investing in me when
it wasn't a sure bet at all that that
was gonna be a good return on their time
but like I've had mentors and people who
just sort of looked at me and for
reasons I don't fully understand and
I've just been super generous with their
time and their wisdom and angel
investing is less about an investment
strategy and more about me wanting to
encourage that next generation of
entrepreneurs to go out and make
something and then trying to help them
in whatever way that I can be successful
and find the joy that there is in
bringing completely new things into the
world that are you know sort of
non-obvious and complicated hmm speaking
of complicated one common theme I hear
from tech researchers here on this
podcast at least the ones who've been
around a while is the
things aren't as easy as they used to be
they're much more complex and in fact a
person you just talked to an der
Salzburg recently said code is getting
bigger and bigger but our brains are not
getting bigger and this is largely a
brain exercise so yes you've been around
a while talk about the increased
complexity you've seen and how that's
impacted the lives and work of computer
scientists and researchers all around I
think interestingly enough on the one
hand it is far more complicated now than
it was say 25 years ago but there's a
flipside to that where we also have a
situation where individual engineers or
small teams have unprecedented amounts
of power in the sense that through
open-source software and cloud computing
and the sophistication of the tools that
they now use and the very high level of
the abstractions that they have access
to that they use to build systems and
products they can just do incredible
things with far fewer resources and in
far shorter spans of time than has ever
been possible it's almost this balancing
act like in the other hand is like the
oh my god the technology ecosystem the
amount of stuff that you have to
understand if you are pushing on the
state-of-the-art on one particular
dimension which is what we're calling
upon researchers to do all the time it's
really just sort of a staggering amount
of stuff I think about how much reading
I had to do when I was PhD student which
seemed like a lot at the time and I just
sort of look at the volume of research
that's being produced in each individual
field right now at the reading burden
form PhD students right now must be
unbelievable and it's sort of similar
you know like if you're a beginning
software engineer like it's a lot of
stuff so it's this weird dichotomy
I think it's perhaps of anything the
right trade-off because if you want to
go make something and you're comfortable
navigating this complexity of the tools
that you have are just incredibly good
I could have done the engineering work
at my first startup with far far far
fewer resources with less money in a
shorter amount of time if I were
building it now versus 2007 but I think
that that tension that you have as a
research or an engineer like this
dissatisfaction that you have with
complexity in this impulse to simplicity
it's exactly the right thing because if
you look at any scientific field this is
just how you make progress listen I was
just thinking when I was in my master's
degree I had to take a statistics class
and the guy who taught it was ancient
and he was mad that we didn't have to do
the math because computer programs could
already do it and he's not wrong it's
like what if your computer breaks can
you do this that's fascinating because
we have this old fart computer
scientists engineers like me have this
like we burn a similar sort of thing all
the time which is these kids these days
they don't know what it was like to load
their computer program into a machine
from a punched paper tape and they don't
know what ferrite core memories are and
what misery that we had to endure it it
was fascinating and fun to you know
learn all of that stuff and I think you
did get something out of it like it gave
you this certain resilience and sort of
fearlessness against these abstraction
boundaries like you know something
breaks like you feel like you can go all
the way down to the very lowest level
and solve the problem but it's not like
you want to do that stuff like although
that's a pain in the ass you can do so
much more now than you could them
because to use your you know statistic
professors phrase because you don't have
to do all of the math
[Music]
your career technology spans the
spectrum including both academic
research and engineering and leadership
in industry so talk about the value of
having experience in both spheres as it
relates to your role now you know the
interesting thing about the research
that I did is I don't know that it ever
had a huge impact the biggest thing that
I ever did was this work on dynamic
binary translation and the thing that
I'm proudest of is like I wrote a bunch
of software that people still use you
know to this day to do research in this
very arcane dark alley of computer
science but what I do use all the time
that is almost like a superpower that I
think you get from being a researcher is
being able to very quickly read and
synthesize a bunch of super complicated
technical information I believe that
it's less about IQ and it's more of the
skill that you learn when you're a
graduate student trying to get yourself
ramped up to mastery and a particular
area it's just like read read read read
read yeah I grew up in this relatively
economically depressed part of rural
central Virginia town of 250 people
neither my parents went to college we
were poor when I grew up and no one
around me was in the computers and like
somehow or another I got into the
Science and Technology high school when
I was a senior and like I decided that I
really really really wanted to be a
computer science professor hmm after
that first year and so I went into my
undergraduate program with this goal in
mind and so I would sit down with things
like the journal of the ACM in the in
the library and convinced oh well like
obviously the computer science
professors need to be able to read and
understand this and I would stare at
papers in the JCM and I'm like oh my god
I'm never ever gonna be
good enough this is impossible but I
just kept at it and yeah got easier by
the time that I was finishing my
undergraduate degree and by the time I
was in my ph.d program I was very
comfortably blasting through stacks of
papers on a on a weekly basis and then
you know towards the end of my ph.d
program you're you're on the program
committees for these things and like not
only are you blasting through stacks of
papers but you're able to blast through
things and understand them well enough
that you can provide useful feedback for
people who've submitted these things for
publication that is an awesome awesome
like super valuable skill to have when
you're an engineering manager if you're
a CTO or you're anybody who's trying to
you know think about where the future of
technology is going so like every person
who is working on their PhD or their
master's degree right now and like this
is part of their training
don't but moan that you're having to do
it you're doing the computer science
equivalent of learning how to play that
list piano concerto you know you're
getting your 10,000 hours at and like
it's gonna be a great thing to have in
your arsenal anymore especially in a
digitally distracted age being able to
pay attention to dense academic papers
and or you know anything for a long
period of time is a superpower it is it
really is you aren't going to accomplish
anything great by you know integrating
information in these little two-minute
chunks I think pushing against the
state-of-the-art like you know creating
something new making something really
valuable requires an intense amount of
concentration over long periods of time
so you came to Microsoft after working
at a few other companies AdMob Google
LinkedIn giving your line of sight into
the work that both Microsoft and other
tech giant's are doing what kind of
perspective do you have on Microsoft's
direction both on the product and
research side and specifically in terms
of strategy and the big bets that this
company's making I think the big tech
companies in particular in this really
interest
position because you have both the
opportunity and the responsibility to
really push the frontier forward the
opportunity in the sense that you like
already have a huge amount of scale to
build on top of and the responsibility
that knowing that some of the new
technologies are just gonna require
large amounts of resources and sort of
patience you know like one example that
we're working on here at Microsoft is we
the industry have been worried about the
end of Moore's law for a very long time
now and it looks like for sort of
general purpose flavors our compute we
are pretty close to the wall right now
and so there are two things that we're
doing at Microsoft right now that are
trying to mitigate part of that so like
one is quantum computing which is a
completely new way to try to build a
computer and to write software and we've
made a ton of progress over the past
several years and our particular
approach to building a quantum computer
is really exciting and it's like this
beautiful collaboration between
mathematicians and physicists and
quantum information theory folks and
systems and programming language folks
trained in computer science but when
exactly this is going to be like a
commercially viable technology I don't
know but another thing that we're you
know pushing on related to this moore's
wall barrier is doing machine learning
where you've got large data sets that
you're fitting models to where you know
sort of the underlying optimization
algorithms that you're using for DNS or
like all the way back to more person a
ik things like logistic regression boil
down to like a bunch of sort of linear
algebra we are increasingly finding ways
to solve these optimization problems in
these embarrassingly parallel ways where
you can use like special flee
compute and so like there's just a bunch
of super interesting work that
everybody's doing with this stuff right
now like from Doug burgers project brain
wave stuff and here at Microsoft so
super exciting time I think to be a
computer architect again where the
magnitude and the potential payoffs of
some of these problems was just
astronomically high and like it takes me
back to the 80s and 90s you know which
were sort of maybe the halcyon days of
high performance computing and these
like big monolithic supercomputers that
we were building at the time and it
feels a lot like that right now where
there's just this palpable excitement
about the progress that we're making
it's funny enough I was having breakfast
this morning with a friend of mine and
you know like both of us were saying man
this is just a fantastic time in
computing you know like on almost weekly
basis I encounter something where I'm
like man this would be so fun to go do a
PhD on yeah and that's a funny sentence
right there yeah it's a funny sentence
[Music]
aside from your day job you're doing
some interesting work in the nonprofit
space particularly with an organization
called behind the tack tell our
listeners about that what do you want to
accomplish what inspired you to go in
that direction yeah a couple of years
ago I I was just looking around at all
of the people that I work with who were
doing truly amazing things and I started
thinking about how important role models
are for both kids who are trying to
imagine a future for themselves as well
as professionals like people who are
already in the discipline who are trying
to imagine what their next step ought to
be and it's always nice to be able to
put yourself in the shoes of someone you
admire and say like oh I can imagine
doing this I can see myself in this you
know in this career and I was like yeah
we just do a poor job I think then we
should on showing the faces and telling
the stories of the people who have made
these major contributions to the
technology that powers our lives and so
that was sort of the impetus behind the
tactile work I some amateur photographer
I started doing these portrait sessions
with the people I know in computing who
I knew had done impressive things and
then I hired someone to help you know so
to interview them and write a slice of
their story so that yeah if you wanted
to go somewhere and get inspired about
people who were making tech you know
behind this act org is the place for you
so you also have a brand new podcast
yourself called behind the tech and you
say that you look at the tech heroes
who've made our modern world possible
I've only heard one and I was super
impressed it's really good I encourage
our listeners to go find behind the tech
podcast tell us why a podcast on these
tech heroes that our unsung
perhaps I have this impulse in general
to try to celebrate the engineer
I'm just so fascinated with the work
that people are doing or have done like
the first episode is with Anders
hallsburg who is a tech fellow at
Microsoft and who's been building
programming languages and development
tools for his entire 35-year career
earlier in his career like he wrote this
programming language and compiler called
turbo Pascal yeah like I wrote my first
real programs using the tools that
Anders built and like he's gone on from
turbo Pascal to building Delphi which
was one of the first really nice
integrated development environments for
graphical user interfaces and then at
Microsoft he was like the chief
architect of the c-sharp programming
language and like now he's building this
programming language based on JavaScript
called typescript that tries to solve
some of the development at scale
problems that JavaScript has and that to
me is like just fascinating how did he
start on this journey like how has he
been able to build these tools that so
many people love what drives and like
I'm just intensely curious about that
and I just want to help share their
story with the rest of the world
do you have other guests that you've
already recorded with or other guests
lined up yeah we've got Alice Stein
glass who is the president of code org
who is doing really brilliant things
trying to help K through 12 students
learn computer science and we're gonna
talk with Andrew in a few weeks who is
one of the Titans of deep neural
networks machine learning and AI we're
gonna talk with Judy estrin who is
former CTO of Cisco serial entrepreneur
board director at Disney and FedEx for a
long time and just you know one of the
og s of Silicon Valley yes so it's you
know like it's gonna be a really good
mix of folks yeah it's fascinating
stories
yeah and just having listened to the
first one I was I mean it was pretty
geeky I will be honest there's a lot of
I was like listening to the mechanics
talking about car engines and I know
nothing but it was right like it was
great it's like you know I hadn't even
thought about it before but like if I
could be like the sort of computer
science and engineering version of car
talk like that would be awesome
you want first place at the William
Campbell High School talent show in 1982
by appearing as a hologram downloaded
from the future okay
maybe not for real but an animated
version of you did explain the idea of
the intelligent edge to a group of
animated high school hecklers assuming
assuming you won't get heckled by our
podcast audience tell us how you feel
like AI and machine learning research
are informing and enabling the
development of edge computing yeah I
think this is one of the more
interesting emergent trends right now in
computing so they're basically three
things that are coming together at the
same time yeah one thing is the growth
of IOT and just embedded computing in
general you can look at any number of
estimates of where we're likely to be
but we're gonna go from about 11 or 12
billion devices connected to the
Internet to about 20 billion over the
next year and a half but you think about
these connected devices and this is sort
of the second trend like they all are
becoming much much more capable so like
they're coming online and like this
silicon and compute power available in
all of these devices is just growing at
a very fast clip and going back to this
whole Moore's Law thing that we were
talking about if you look at two and
three dollar microprocessor or
microcontrollers
most of those things right now are built
on two or three generations older
process technology so they are going to
increase in power significantly over the
coming years particularly this flavor of
power that you need to run AI models
which is sort of a third trend so like
you've got huge number of devices being
connected with more and more compute
power and the compute power is going to
enable more and more intelligent
software to be written using the sensor
data that these devices are processing
and so like those three things together
we're calling the intelligent edge and
we're entering this world where you'll
step into a room and like they're gonna
be dozens and dozens of computing
devices in the room and you'll interface
with them by voice and gesture and like
a bunch of other sort of intangible
factors where you won't even be aware of
them anymore and so that implies like a
huge set of changes in the way that we
write software like how do you build a
user experience for these things how do
you deal with information security and
data privacy in these environments just
even programming these things is going
to be fundamentally different it's a
super exciting time and it's certainly
something that we are investing very
heavily in right now and Microsoft in
the particular sense of like how do we
take the best of our development tools
the best of our platform technology the
best of our a I and the best of our
cloud to let people build these
solutions where it's not as hard as it
is right now well you know everything
you've said leads me into the question
that I wanted to circle back on from the
beginning of the interview which is that
the current focus on a ai' machine
learning cloud computing all of the
things that are just like the hot core
of Microsoft researches Center they have
amazing potential to both benefit our
society and also change the way we
interact with things is there anything
about what you're seeing and what you've
been describing that keeps you up at
night I mean without putting too dark a
cloud on it what are your thoughts on
that
the number one thing is I'm worried that
we are actually under appreciating the
positive benefit that some of these
technologies can have and are not
investing as much as we could be
holistically to make sure that they get
into the hands of consumers in a way
that benefits society more quickly and
so like just to give you an example of
what I mean we have healthcare costs
right now that are growing faster than
our gross domestic product and I think
the only way in the limit that you bend
the shape of that health care cost
growth curve is through the intervention
of some sort of technology and like week
after week over the past 18 months I've
seen one technology after another that
is AI base where you sort of combine
medical data or personal sensor data
with this new regime of deep neural
networks and you're able to solve these
medical diagnostic problems at
unbelievably low costs that are able to
very early detect fairly serious
conditions that people have when the
conditions are cheaper and easier to
treat and where you know the benefit to
the patient like the you know they're
healthier in the limit and so I sort of
see technology after technology in this
vein that is really gonna bring higher
quality medical care to everyone for
cheaper and help us get ahead of these
yeah sort of significant diseases that
folks have you know there's a similar
trend in precision agriculture where in
terms of crop yields and minimizing
environmental impacts
particularly in the developing world
where you still have large portions of
the world's population sort of trapped
in this yes an agricultural subsistence
dynamic AI could fundamentally change
you know the way that we're all living
our lives all the way from you know like
all of us getting sort of cheaper better
locally grown organic produce with
smaller environmental impact you know
like how does a subsistence farmer in
India dramatically increase their crop
yields so that they can elevate the
economic status of their entire family
and community so as we wrap up Kevin
what advice would you give to emerging
researchers or budding technologists in
our audience as many of them are
contemplating what they're going to do
next
well I think congratulations is in order
to most folks because this is a this is
like just about as good a time I think
is has ever been for someone to pursue a
career in computer science research or
to become an engineer
that means the advice that I would give
to folks is like just look for ways to
maximize the impact of what you're doing
and so like I think with research it's
sort of the same advice that I would
give to you folks starting a company or
engineers thinking about the next thing
that they should go off and build in the
context of a company find a trend that
is really a fast growth driver like the
amount of available AI training compute
or the amount of data being produced by
the world in general or by some
particular you know sub component of our
digital world
just pick a growth driver like that and
try to you know attempt something that
is either buoyed by that growth driver
or that is directly in the growth loop
because I think those are the
opportunities that tend to have both the
most Headroom in terms of yeah like if
there are lots of people working on a
particular problem it's great if the
space
that you're working in the problem
itself has a gigantic potential upside
those things will usually like
accommodate lots and lots and lots of
sort of simultaneous activity on them
and not be winner-takes-all or a winner
takes most dynamic you know and they're
also sort of the interesting problems as
well you know sort of thrilling to be on
a rocket ship in general Kevin Scott
thanks for taking time out of your super
busy life to chat with us you are very
welcome thank you so much for having me
off it was a pleasure to learn more
about Kevin Scott and Microsoft's vision
for the future of computing visit
microsoft.com/testlabguides
[Music]